si el presidente ruso vladimir putin ha
firmado una orden que permitirá a los
rusos ya las compañías rusas pagar las
patentes los derechos de propiedad
intelectual en rublos la medida afecta a
unos 45 países son los países
denominados por el gobierno ruso como
países inamistosos aquellos como por
ejemplo la unión europea eeuu o reino
unido que han impuesto sanciones a rusia
por sus operaciones en ucrania y también
aquellos países ha explicado el jefe de
estado ruso que han desacreditado
informativamente a las fuerzas armadas
rusas por las actividades del ejército
ruso en ucrania se trata de una medida
unilateral a la que se tengan que
amoldar estos países si quieren cobrar
la propiedad intelectual tendrán que
abrir cuentas en rublos para cobrar las
también ha sido muy duro por cierto el
ministro de asuntos exteriores ruso
serguéi lávrov que ha criticado una
cruzada mundial contra todo lo ruso que
afecta según lávrov a la cultura a
artistas como tchaikovsky o 23 que están
siendo según la broma ahora mismo
cancelados